jean marc sylvestre bonjour ravi de vous
retrouver dans l'édito de la matinale
alors une première question qu'est ce
qui permet de penser que la pandémie
recule un peu partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui
vous savez bonjour d'abord on a une
série de chiffres c'est vrai qu'ils
sortent notamment de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé on a aussi des
séries de chiffres qui viennent de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce on a
une amélioration sur le front de la
pandémie on a une amélioration est liée
directement sur le fond de l'économie
alors l'attention des médias se
focalisent dans des pays ou des régions
qui sont encore en risque grave c'est
vrai mais si on prend les chiffres de
contamination dans le monde entier
ben on s'aperçoit qu'ils ont beaucoup
baissé le virus a reculé pratiquement de
moitié en moyenne
or on s'aperçoit ainsi que le nombre
d'entrées dans l'est dans des hôpitaux à
stagner ou même à baisser notamment
réanimation le taux d'incidence serait
tombé à peu près en dessous de zéro dans
beaucoup de pays occidentaux donc les
courbes qu'on a en france sont à peu
près à la moyenne mondiale ils sont
baissières cette moyenne cache un
certain nombre de disparités qui impacte
bien sûr fortement des situations
économiques avec simplement une
incertitude c'est l'impact du variant
notamment du vaillant anglais au du
variant d'afrique du sud on peut
considérer vous le disiez que les
chinois sont complètement sortis
d'affaires on peut considérer que les
américains voient actuellement le bout
du tunnel
peut-être que les la situation en grande
bretagne est sans doute en train de
s'améliorer grâce à des campagnes de
vaccination qui ont été très massives
très performante donc dans ces pays
la situation économique est en train de
reprendre
l'union européenne est encore à la
traîne c'est vrai et plus
particulièrement la france et pourquoi
l'europe at elle du retard notamment
dans le domaine économique tient à
écouter vous avez fait un certain nombre
de reportages qui montrent qu' il ya
beaucoup de manque de coordination ça
veut dire de 4 de cafouillage mais c'est
un peu vrai notamment quand on regarde
ce qui s'est passé sur sur les vaccins
ça vous a pas échappé l'europe se
compose de 27 états nations qui sont pas
coordonnées notamment en matière de
santé parce que la politique de santé ne
fait pas partie des compétences
européennes sauf
au niveau des vaccins ou la commission a
pris sa nombre d'initiatives notamment
en matière d'achats et le succès n'était
pas 13 au rendez vous donc les
traitements de la pandémie sont partis
un peu dans tous les sens alors la
circulation alors que la circulation des
hommes n'a jamais été interdites at on
appris des pays qui aurait eu des
procédures de confinement un peu
différente on a décrit regardez
l'allemagne présent qui commence
aujourd'hui à fermer ses frontières en
contravention avec les avec les les
accords européens
ça s'améliore actuellement vous un petit
peu parce que les états ont commencé à
se protéger à s'enfermer donc là ça a
des résultats il ya un deuxième facteur
c'est que l'europe et enfin parce que
l'europe a été incapable d'organiser des
campagnes de vaccination massives alors
ça c'est vraiment le point faible ce
qu'ont fait les pays d'asie ce qu'a fait
la russie ce qu'ont fait les états unis
surtout ou la grande bretagne ne l'avons
pas nous les doses nécessaires et comme
nous en achetons ça en dehors des
protocoles europe et en france notamment
aux vaccins reçus au vaccin chinois qui
sont bons et et on le fait pas pour des
raisons politiques et bien ça ne fait
permet pas d'avancer dans la vaccination
ça va s'arranger tout ça mais ça va
prendre un peu de temps donc ça on va
prendre un peu de retard le troisième
facteur de repas c'est qu'on est quand
même incapable comme en france
l'organisé le dépistage on est incapable
d'organiser le traçage et puis un
visionnement de cas positifs ça s'est
toujours considéré comme des atteintes à
la liberté individuelle doit absolument
être égaux donc pour être égaux cette
égalité cela on doit être tous confinés
alors qu'on pourrait très bien faire
circuler un certain nombre de gens qui
sont ou immunisés naturellement parce
qu'ils ont déjà eu copie
ou alors parce qu'ils sont déjà vaccinés
ou alors parce que ils ont ils ont testé
ça permettrait de mettre d'un côté les
cas contaminants et puis d'un autre côté
les cas ils ne sont pas forcément
dangereux pour le reste de la population
on aurait donc besoin de tests on a
besoin de pâques star est sans doute
très prochainement avec des certificats
de vaccination ou des certificats de
testing ce qu'on a fait en israël elle
fait des reportages la à leur très
intéressant sûr mais on pourrait en
faire en nouvelle zélande on pourrait
singapour pour regarder ce qui se passe
en chinois à taiwan avec une circulation
du virus qu'on a absolument tenu à zéro
en france les entreprises de théâtre
même les entreprises tout à fait normal
les restaurants aurait besoin de savoir
si les gens qu'ils accueillent auquel
pourrait accueillir sont porteurs ou pas
du virus expérience que fait d'ailleurs
aux inrh mme bachelot avec ses concerts
test va être très très intéressante
parce que là on sent bien la pédagogie
est en train d'avancer si on teste les
gens à l'entrée de la salle pour savoir
qui est positif et négatif et bien on
pourra en toi trier entre guillemets
même si le mot n'est pas très joli et
préserver ce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont
porteurs sort et de ce qui ne me sont
pas avoir donc voilà en gros la
situation on a un problème de pédagogie
et de conviction à faire passer au
niveau de la population française
accepter le traçage accepté 10 ans ils
ont marqué comment est ce que vous voyez
la situation économique en france
alors elle est directement impacté
directement impactés par la façon dont
on traite le virus sévit dans la chine a
retrouvé son activité économique normale
les etats unis sont en train de
redémarrer je vous le disais l'europe
elle est encore un peu en panne
elle restera en panne tant qu'on n'aura
pas réglé la stratégie vaccinale donc
leur va prendre au moins six mois de
retard par rapport aux autres pays
peut-être même six mois par rapport à la
grande-bretagne d'autant que l'europe a
beaucoup de difficultés pour coordonner
son plan de relance économique
il ya la vaccination yahia la pandémie
mais il ya aussi le plan de relance
économique
vous avez bien que le plan qui avait été
signé en juillet l'année dernière n'a
pas encore été adoubé si j'ose dire par
l'ensemble des parlements s'attira est
un peu dans tous les sens ce qui veut
dire que 2021 ne permettra sans doute
pas de compenser des pertes on a à peu
près 700 à 800 milliards d'euros qui
n'ont pas été versés pour financer ces
plans de relance on ne sait pas défini
exactement à poux à quoi pouvait servir
ses plans de relance on a l'argent on a
des taux d'intérêt pratiquement zéro qui
permettent d'en obtenir encore davantage
mais on n'a pas encore très bien défini
que ce qu'on pouvait en faire alors la
france c'est pas très bien en toi dans
cette affaire tous les moyens existent
pour redémarrer très forme savez les
entreprises existe un l'argent existe
vous avez vu les comptes d'épargné
qui ce départ qui n'est pas utilisée
kelly qui est disponible les clients les
commerces des entreprises sont très
résiliente vous avez des personnels qui
sont assez fatigué d'ailleurs du
télétravail franchement ils ont
peut-être envie de revenir revoir leurs
confrères et leurs bureaux la machine à
café nous manque beaucoup et bien vous
avez tout ça système qui est en plus
sous perfusion de l'état la principale
difficulté va être d'enlever ses débuts
ses perfusions notamment celle de
subventions seul du chômage partiel et
voir comment ça peut marcher toute seule
l'activité est soutenue
il manque deux choses pour que ça
redémarre très fort il manque quoi mais
manque sa confiance et la confiance
elle vient de la vaccination du testage
du traçage de l'isolément de tous les
mécanismes que l'on n'hésite à utiliser
franchement les yeux tout est pourquoi
les autres tests sont-ils bloqués en
france alors qu'il commence à être
utilisé dans beaucoup de pays qui
permettrait en cinq six minutes de
savoir si on est contaminé ou si on ne
l'est pas merci beaucoup
jean marc jean marc sylvestre qu'on
retrouve tous les mercredis matins dans
l'édito de la matinale